[Music]
um
so the title of this video is
uh crazy drunk or just crazy
here we go have you had anything to
drink tonight no nothing to drink nope
i'm a very dramatic person my man broke
up with me grabbing my id like you asked
me to did i ask
okay
first i want to say
no one in the chat fall in love
okay we stopped at last night we need us
yeah you guys need to [ __ ] get get a
grip all right do you hear me
they sense weakness they're like sharks
blood in the water
what's your name he has my name i don't
know your name i don't know my name
either it's because i'm psychology
holy [ __ ] imagine a straight line in
front of me no i can't wait can i fix my
city let me fix that
can i fix my titty let me fix my titty a
lot of people in the chat are saying the
same thing i can fix her
[Music]
smash
or pass
i mean she is crazy well i didn't say
that you have to marry her um
but then you wake up with your dick cut
off and super glued to your thigh
okay i'm up i put the poll up we'll see
what happens
let's see
my vote is smash but don't give her your
real name or information yes yes yes
[Music]
i'm excited for this one guys
[Music]
he's already had it just listen
that's it
okay the reason why i got called out is
because of the little scene that you
caused with the gas station all right
word well i didn't hit nobody i didn't
do nothing so i'm on the side of the
road and i'm crying and that's it that's
all you need to know okay well that's
not all i'm investigating i
didn't commit a crime i didn't do
anything wrong
so that's it
have you had anything to drink tonight
nope
i think she has
nothing to drink nope
yes i'm a very dramatic person
[Laughter]
i just found out i had herpes
whoa never mind no i don't want to smash
hold on let me let me can i i gotta
google something if we google something
google
hold on
how to
[Music]
unfold
[Laughter]
i don't think you can guys
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
and right now it's 53 percent
it's legally binding now it's a chat
saying
oh wrong
51 49 oh it's shifting oh it's shifting
it's shifting very quickly guys
this is 4 a.m on election night
it's [ __ ] turning oh boy pass is 52
now pass is at 52.
oh boy
oh no
everyone's going abort abort abort abort
abort
now you have to [ __ ] her
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] now the whole chat has herpes
somebody's has a good point it's that 54
pass now by the way
jeffy sweats glad i waited
it's fair three olives they tried to
warn us and we ignored them that's fair
it's fair we did ignore him
but look
that's neither here nor there
i never voted on the poll so it doesn't
matter to me uh the the chat is now
blaming you for a recent herpes outbreak
sorry guys i'm really sorry
my man broke up with me
probably because of the herpes yeah
and i just got burned 250
that's it
so i'm crying my face up trying to find
my [ __ ] phone
trying to contact my man dude i didn't
commit any crime so you can kiss my ass
with your [ __ ]
well they want you trespassing the gas
station that's fine
yo go ahead write that [ __ ] up dawg i
don't give a [ __ ] dawg
don't go to your you're gonna play with
me don't go to your car
i'm driving my id like you asked me did
i ask
boss
every second of this video is amazing
and it's 27 minutes long
oh toshi saying she might be she's
puerto rican
probably
where is this at does it say
you usually put it down
no
huh we'll figure it didn't ask you to
grab your idea better lose your [ __ ]
attitude
right
better
now
your [ __ ] attitude with me i'm trying
to be cool with you but i could only
take so much all right
i mean to be fair she's crazy but she's
allowed to have an attitude
you keep it up you're going to be
putting cuffs
she modeling now what's going on here
she's trying to do something you know is
it working
i don't think so
probably because of the herpes the the
car as soon as the cop heard herpes that
it's all off the table now what's your
birthday uh oh oh how old do you think
she is now we're about to know how do
you think she is
late 30s
no uh-uh
late 20s that's how rough she is
that's my guys let's find out
what's your first name you can't find
out
if you don't provide me with your first
name i'm going to charge you with
concealing identity okay
you just
told me not to go into my vehicle
to grab my id so which one is it boss
i want you to identify yourself by your
first name last name and date of birth
yeah i can grab my id so that you can do
that i don't know what's in your vehicle
i don't know what's in my vehicle either
i kind of feel like you should know
what's in your vehicle
i'm not concealing my identity i'm
trying to get you my ideas so that i can
provide identification just like you
asked me to i get that
what's your first name last name
i'm trying to provide you with my i
don't want you to go inside your vehicle
okay
because i don't know what's in there
your vehicle is obviously running i
don't want you to take off me all right
so i'm not going to let you get anything
out of your vehicle
taste the herpes out of her i don't
think that it works like that yeah i
know that's not how it works i just want
to reach for my wallet that's right
there can i drive your wallet grab my
wallet okay you'll grab it
yeah i can grab it he's going to grab
him
it's right there
yeah yeah
sorry she's so she is she's not just
drunk there's something else right
i don't think you should put your hands
up i mean besides being crazy do we play
the game
i
mean am i it might just be i don't know
she might also be it's also i think it's
it's crazy pills too
i don't think that's a good idea hey i
have to go potty so can i use the bush
right there right quick or not hold up
before they get me into booking can i
just try to be out of here
yes are you sure thank you very much i
don't want you starting this
confidence that she has with this whole
thing yeah i know
nothing about nothing
[Music]
i heard a female cop
yeah she's puerto rican
i'm great man how are you doing tonight
you all right
what's going on
just trying to help with the female cop
what's wrong why don't you talk to me
it's okay listen
and she's crying
and she broke down
and she's done
wow that was a quick [ __ ]
[Music]
people are saying smash would swoop in
at this moment 56 pass i'm just trying
my ass off because my man just left me
your man won't love her
that's why she's doing all this
that's good
it's because i knew he was cheating on
me so i wait and i went to guppy hall
wait wait wait wait wait wait
did you hear that
i knew he was cheating on me so i went
to go be a hoe is that what you said
yeah i think that's what she said let me
see if i could throw throw closed
captions on this bad boy
i wonder why you cheated on her then um
this lady's so crazy she took the stream
down
she's [ __ ] nuts all right uh
there you go
should be back should be back she'll be
back
okay
can you do me a favor can you stand like
me and you see how my feet are close
together you just stand like that how
about this
she's she's doing a dui test on her now
you sound like don't train me like i'm a
[ __ ] criminal because
i mean nothing wrong eh
hey
she's not mexican she might be mexican
i just texas if it's texas she's mexican
i don't like nothing wrong
she doesn't look like a mexican though
okay what's going on
[Music]
oh she's [ __ ] up
[Music]
it thinks cause i'm psycho
44 smash
do you think the craziness kind of she
ripped her pockets look at her pocket
she ripped her pocket
she she had one of those like pockets up
here and she ripped it
what was that did you see that
let me go back a little bit here
to request that you continue okay
this is the type of chick
that will
stab you in the dick to make sure you
don't cheat again
right this is insane
when i just got burned 250 dollars and
so i'm very very upset
i didn't want to drive while i'm upset
so i pulled off onto the road
and i just started sitting here because
i didn't want to drive when i was upset
i didn't want to drive while i was upset
i didn't want to drive stupid or nothing
or nothing or nothing or nothing or
nothing or nothing
i just wanted to stay here i just wanted
to cry
everyone's saying this is hispanic
harley quinn hey
[Music]
yeah i have no idea
it's okay
yeah we got this
is she bowing up is that what she was
doing
what does that would mean you're gonna
fight them like what's going on here
yeah
i didn't do nothing about nothing
i didn't know nothing about nothing
she's mexican
yeah yeah she's mexican
we just want to make sure you're okay
okay we came out here to make sure
you're okay
oh yeah she could be mexican i see it
now
bianca
[Music]
all right let me tell you something let
me tell you something
my homie snakes she was right down the
way
i wasn't knocking on no windows first of
all
i don't know what you guys are talking
about she's a dime piece
ken
look man i know you're gay you're trying
to like knock people off your scent and
stuff but like
you know this is not better
yeah
45
smash
so i there boom i was backed into a park
there might be new people that came in
she also has herpes
over here right here in this lot never
forget and then
i hopped out
and my homie snakes was like all right
my homie snakes
and i'll be back
all right
but then
i see this 12 year old little boy
homie sticks my homie snakes
okay
fine as well can i get you number one
you're like 12 months
i was like you're kidding me you're cute
as [ __ ] but
oh no
you know what my respect
where's snakes at
he just laughed
[Music]
we're snakes guys
i want snake side of the story
by the way the women in the chat are now
fawning over the male cop over there
45 smash
[Music]
it's just 180 after 180. boom boom
i have a mental disorder and that's why
i'm acting the way i'm acting
no [ __ ] you think she you think you
think she does it's okay
not because i have
any
any intoxication of the sort
of the sort
this may be the craziest woman i've ever
seen
okay will you be willing to submit the
saturday festival
yes absolutely okay can you [ __ ] off
with your stupid [ __ ]
where they're right there yeah right
here there's not even a shirt right
there if you were in the cop shoes how
would you deal with this
i wouldn't be a cop so
i don't know
i mean at this point i would have just
arrested her for wrong good
you know what i mean
and maybe take her to a mental hospital
you know
yeah how the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
this right that's what the [ __ ]
with no straight line for
full
you got me [ __ ] up g what you're gonna
say uh this [ __ ] didn't pass cause x x
y and z
man she is [ __ ] crazy
on your [ __ ] state of mind
tell me when you're done
so i could explain this to you there you
go
keep your feet together yeah as right
click your side you're gonna follow the
tip of my pen with your eyes and your
eyes only okay do not move from this
position what if i cry
[Laughter]
what am i crying
i hear you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
on your discretion that's what you got
me because i'm following your tip full
and you didn't like done five or six
times
[Music]
is this the best body cam footage we've
ever seen i think this might be the best
one this is the best one i've ever seen
pessy
jj you missed one hell of a body cam
footage
but because my eyes can't go that far
that's why you're [ __ ] docking me
[ __ ]
will you have that [ __ ] wait the [ __ ]
out here full
and now that you shine the light on it
it should have been a pass to begin with
huh
uh-huh cause you really couldn't tell
because it was dark but once you once
you light up that bad boy that ain't the
best that is bad
instructions
okay oh yeah she's mexican though that's
for sure
guys in the chat mm-hmm
just forget that she has her piece you
cow
just
erase it the herpes doesn't forget she
has herpes
you can try
you can't that's sorry
that's like saying pretend 9 11 didn't
happen
no it [ __ ] happened
fine fine we're leaving your
hypothetical world where this woman
doesn't have herpes go ahead
ask your question go ahead
would you as the chat still
go with it no because i would assume she
has herpes
[Laughter]
hope that answers your question this has
been my ted talk
there she lucas came i'd smash without
herpes
all right whatever man good i guess
because it's not up to you apart that's
why you're pissed
all right
osiris smash i already have herpes
by the way now that i'm looking at her
mouth it looks like seymour should be
feeding her like his dentist his body
oh yeah feed me yeah
oh it's in my face
oh it's big mouth
i learned how to follow him
you know what it looks like royce
uh mr big mouth from uh
rocco's modern life yes
yeah the big heads
sorry
45 smash
and he used to beat the [ __ ]
[Music]
what pretty face
is it sheila
exactly
okay
look at her mouth
i can't do that if i wanted to
what was that one
[Music]
do you think she's like calling whales
for something
[Music]
horrible chili recipe
those lips could suck a golf ball
through a garden hose yeah but no
policemen
please
[Music]
could you imagine a straight line right
here in front of you there is no
straight line
could you could you imagine a straight
line no i can't because i i just started
saying that i imagined like quack
she walks crooked man that's the problem
at this point the amount of time she
just
like keeps walking and giving distance
from the cops yeah
yeah
if i were to do that we'd get like
tased already
don't touch me fool please don't touch
me
you from getting hit you're yeah right
you're just scared he's gonna run
i'm not doing nothing i'm not doing
nothing okay listen listen closer brings
up a very good hypothesis
every time she brings her hair up to the
side ponytail she she flips on the black
voice got it
okay so that that that activates it
i think she has like
this is real d.i.d i think
this is real d-r-u-g yes
bianca are you going to do these tests
yes i am and i'm trying to tell you that
i'm so rude
she just did it now and she's not doing
black voice okay
baby you're gonna think i'm walking
crooked because i know it's not it's
so i'm going to give you the
instructions okay
like that
so you
no i can't
but thank you for asking
okay well imagine there was a straight
line finish okay put your left foot
directly on top of that line
i can't imagine a straight line sir
she can't it's impossible it's not
within her realm of imagination but i'm
trying to explain to you that it's gonna
go either this way it's probably gonna
go this way and if you're gonna arrest
me on that
then [ __ ] you and where the [ __ ] you
came from
like i'm not trying to [ __ ] do
nothing wrong
can i give you the instructions
okay imagine the line here can you
imagine a straight line right in front
of you okay i hear you put your left
foot on top of that line uh-huh
put your right foot directly in front of
your left foot touching heel to toe just
like me
okay you're gonna put your hands
directly at your side no i can't because
my hair gets in my face and then i can't
walk straight you're planning
heel to toe steps back okay
here i go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
five
six seven eight
this is a combination of things corey
i don't even have a straight line
[Music]
there is no canadian accent except
my blood alcatel level blood alcohol
content and some more stupid [ __ ] and
i'm just trying to tell you that i have
mental health issues
i'm extremely distraught
i feel like my whole life is that king
distraught that's something why don't
you understand that's a big word for
mexican isn't it okay i'm tired i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry just trying to comply
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm just trying to complain
but please let him okay we're gonna do
the next test okay okay
put your feet together and hands
directly at your side okay
do not move from this position until i
instruct you to start the test do you
understand
yes from here you're gonna pick a foot
of your choice left or right doesn't
matter which one lift it apart we're
still doing this like this
and i think i did for a little bit
at this point you arrest her right
i just yeah yeah yeah yeah can you hang
out on your hood
i grab my ipad
is
[Music]
hold
we're hoping for it
god that's all i want
okay
i understand
snap your feet close together right
there
yeah i'm leaning towards crazy more than
drunk honestly i mean she is drunk
obvious also but i think this is more
because crazy this last time we slept
last night last night what did we take
today
when did i take yeah what did we take
today
yeah i i don't think do it dope but i'm
not under the influence right now okay
no i'm not i swear to god guys
what did she say she took
she's on dope but she she swears she's
not on the under the influence
oh no
i need to make sure you're okay i am i'm
just in this draw because my boyfriend
just left me why don't you get that i'm
sorry
please don't take
she calls cute cop yeah i'm surprised
she hasn't taken a swing i'm being
honest with you you know
you can't touch your sword okay okay
that's why i'm telling you not to touch
your legs
so i automatically feel like over
exactly
[Music]
no that could be because of that
i'm being arrested for yeah okay
i'm gonna put the clips on you oh man
okay
oh boy well cups are on at least what
did i do wrong at least tell me what i'm
being charged with [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
relax right now right relax
tell me what i'm being charged with now
tell me what i'm being charged with
what suspicion of dw suspicion of dwi
suspicion of bwi
i'm requesting to get you a bac i'm
requesting now okay we'll go get you one
hour
wow
yes now
where's your thing now where's your
thing relax
translation i'm not gonna deal
she's clearly crazy bro
i'm not eating
i need a bic now okay let's go get there
i'm not i'm not drunk were you ready get
off a mistake i'm asking you a [ __ ]
question
that's no
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah it was
and there's some brave guys in the chat
right now do you hear the screen kind of
hot do you show the screaming
bro
that was the craziest one i've ever seen
that has to be the craziest one i've
ever seen
holy [ __ ] again a reminder for those who
are saying smash in the chat she has
herpes
i don't think some of these [ __ ] give
a [ __ ] frozen